hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
somehow I have reached 100,000
subscribers I know what you're thinking
how the hell can this annoying tub of
lard have 100k
I completely agree to commemorate these
six digits though I thought we should
look at what makes game is such freaking
brilliant people here are eight
life-changing skills that every video
gamer develops I'm sure in the past
you've played something like destiny
Monster Hunter or World of Warcraft they
are very different games but they all
include a grind element to repeatedly
complete a task to move closer to a goal
or objective gamers will put in
countless hours to grind to glory but
how can that be a life-changing skill
it's surprisingly simple in a world of
fast food instant streaming and next day
deliveries video games teachers patience
perseverance and dedication if you want
that once-in-a-lifetime Black Knight
skin in for tonight battle royale well
be prepared to play for over a hundred
hours to get it we may be quite a fickle
bunch that we definitely had dedicated I
may be over selling this next point but
social understanding can change the
world xenophobia or the fear or dislike
of people from other countries can lead
to political unrest and in the very
worst cases even war well video gamers
are some of the most understanding and
accepting people around yeah there are
some keyboard warriors and some
simpletons who use video games as a
vehicle for their hate but generally
gamers are open to playing a game with
anyone in the world unless there's lag
of course lag ruins everything and
breaks down all relationships from my
personal experience thanks to video
games I now regularly play with people
from the USA from the Netherlands from
South Africa and I'm even proud to say I
have a friend from the federated states
of micronesia
I won't lie I have no idea where that
was but Thank You Google Earth everyone
is born equal in the video game world a
seemingly forgotten emotion in modern
day media is empathy the ability to put
yourself in someone else's shoes and
share their
oceans oh I know what it feels like
fella believe me a dab will make you
feel better
movies have given us an insight into the
lives of others but video games take
empathy to the next level games like
heavy rain which put you in the shoes of
a father whose son has been kidnapped by
a serial killer being forced through
countless tests of love and commitment
including some really harrowing shots of
self harm and the polar opposite to that
the more mundane papers please which
interest the player with working at an
immigration checkpoint in a war-torn
country balancing the rules of the
country with the pressures of making
enough money to clothe and feed your
family video gamers understand and
experience so much joy so much pain
sorrow non-gamers you'd be surprised in
real life I'm a teacher I know I know
unsubscribe right away run for the hills
I get it
but seeing things from a teacher's point
of view really helps with a next
life-changing skill on our list and it
is learning new concepts quickly let's
say you play 12 new games every single
year so on those 12 occasions a typical
gamer is forced to learn new rules
mechanics and small variations to the
controls I'm going to use force Knight
as the example again
not only are we forced to use five slots
in our loadout we also need to master a
building mechanic with 50 variations
layered on top of that there is a
physics engine which takes into account
bullet drop and building degradation
damn when you think about it if you've
won a game in fortnight battle royale
your freaking legend
a gamers ability to pick up new skills
almost instantaneously is also
reinforced through peer-to-peer learning
the warframe community has this one
nailed down with veteran players
actively searching help newcomers to
pass knowledge on to the more I go
through this list the more proud I feel
to be a gamer
did you ever enjoy history class yeah it
could be a little dry at times
once again video games have our backs
not only can we read about historical
events we can experience them storming
the beaches of Normandy ending the gods
of Olympus and even shooting jf Kennedy
okay some things we've done video games
completely messed up but our
understanding of history mythology fact
or fiction is greatly improved by video
games being told is all well and good
but experiencing something for yourself
helps you retain it for life but we need
to make sure we don't get our
alternative and actual histories mixed
up I don't think Hitler is still alive
like Wolfenstein teaches us but I do
know for certain that Kratos really did
pull off Helios his head right
due to the vast number of games we play
it should come as almost no surprise
that video gamers have the ability to
solve problems but that's not the only
thing studies have also shown that video
gamers adapts to situations faster and
solve problems much quicker than the
average job this leads to the next point
to reverse aging keeping your brain
active and stretching it where possible
is beyond measurable I'm sure you've
played the brain training games Nintendo
release many moons ago since then many
studies have shown that playing video
games can reverse the effects of aging
I'm not saying the crow's feet will go
away or the retirement belly will turn
back into a six-pack but for people as
old as me dare I say it I'm in my 30s
knowing videogames are going to keep my
brain healthy is a great feeling for an
old man like me and let's finish with
hand-eye coordination it's always been
the beacon of light in any debate about
negative effect of video games it's
generally accepted that the hand-eye
coordination of a video gamer is akin to
a surgeon anyone fancy switching
professions video game recreations of
operations have now been used for over
ten years to train future surgeons so
the next time someone is removing your
appendix know they learned how to do
this on surgeon simulator
Karami yes yes just shove it in there we
have a different approach to 100k
subscriber video 8 ways video gamers are
freaking brilliant so the next time
someone tells you about the negative
effects of video gaming remind them
about our patience perseverance and
dedication our social understanding
unacceptance our ability to empathize
our speed of learning our active
knowledge of history and mythology our
hand-eye coordination and our
problem-solving skill set damn it we are
awesome I'm Adam from Playstation
grenades if you fancy chatting with me
and like-minded gamers I'll throw the
link to our discord below this has been
an absolute pleasure but a break from
the norm so rest assured next time I
released a video it will be back to the
usual format
[Music]